feels honestly like i'm working in a
coding like environment because
[Music]
let's go take a looksie
oh
holy
wow
it's so open
wow
it's so open
we have so much space
wow
this is amazing
wow it feels like a completely different
room
dang
how cool
[Music]
we were from a cafe this morning and
then we stopped by
a sushi place that's been around forever
i talked to the owner and he thought i
was still in high school
and i told him i was 30. he was like you
look like you could be in your teams so
we got some pokeball and we're gonna eat
we're watching the waves
i love living here
[Music]
hello everybody happy monday just wanted
to show you progress on our kitchen reno
because there has been a lot of progress
since i last vlog it's actually
so echo in here because we don't have
anything on our first floor but check it
out
everything is gone
and we actually just put up all this
drywall today
it was like down to the studs for a very
long time
but scott and i blue taped everything
where everything should be
and we got rid of that wall that used to
be there it's just looking so much
better
and brighter
super excited so yeah it's literally
been quite the journey and embarking on
this kitchen right now we've been
i think it's almost been a month since
we started goes to show how often i vlog
between like doing electrical work
plumbing work
drywalling
uncovering things and then figuring out
okay now what do we do because this
wasn't what we in what we thought we'd
encounter we've uh made it work our
contractor is really dope it's been kind
of fun it feels
honestly like i'm working in a coding
like environment because
you're just kind of peeling back the
layers and seeing how things work and
then trouble
shooting and problem solving throughout
so it's kind of been fun construction is
fun although i will say
i really miss having a kitchen we don't
have the kitchen
right now in fact i'll show you the
kitchen set up right afterwards that we
do have we've been eating out a lot
which has not been good
for
the digestion
but it's actually been okay we've been
eating a lot of like salad and trying to
eat as healthy as possible but i did
also need a burger today
so
yeah
contractor's gonna start building
cabinets already and we've like selected
our
cabinet color our hardware our lighting
our countertop which is going to be this
really cool black color
so things are coming together and i'm
really freaking excited honestly more
than anything i'm excited to furnish
this whole space because scott and i
have just basically been living upstairs
in like an apartment style thing which
has been fine it's been great plenty of
space for us
but it would be nice to use the entire
other half of the house that we own this
is our
mock kitchen situation here so our
fridge
is just sitting there it works it's
plugged in and then our dining table
with this tarp
that just is there for dust
has all of our kitchen gadgets on it so
i still have our air fryer
and our
rice cooker and a little like induction
cooktop back there so we can cook if we
really want to in fact we've been
grilling a fair amount so it hasn't been
too bad i mean yesterday i was really
craving rice
so i made rice and i also made ramen so
it's not too terrible i feel like with
renovations my
impression of how it goes is like it's
chaos but that's because of the reality
tv shows and it to a certain extent it
is like
it's loud sometimes and there's dust
everywhere and you can't live in your
full space but we've learned that we're
pretty flexible adaptable people
and when problems come up we solve them
not too terribly hard like for us
surprisingly it's been kind of an
interesting journey to learn that like
we can do it if we need to but granted
we're also very fortunate to live near
our friends who allow us to like come
stay with them sometimes and use their
kitchen whenever we're feeling
particularly like
construction is like starting to get to
us so that's been helping to just
relieve some of the construction stress
too this kitchen is going to be so
awesome scott and i are going to film so
much stuff in it our plan is to kind of
make some more food content and stuff
maybe on tick tock i don't know
not going to write it in stone you'll
find out as i post these things because
who knows what i'll actually do but i
think it'll be a really nice like
filmable kitchen so very excited for
that hello and happy wednesday everybody
i just finished filming a video for a
non-profit that i've been working with
for the last what is it may it's like in
like three months i'm working with a
non-profit called rewriting code and
i've been developing a web series for
them called real talk
where we talk about real conversations
about being women in tech so i just
finished filming episode four which is
about money in tech it's been really fun
i've been getting to talk about
different topics that i want to talk
about with people in their community so
it's been kind of interesting to just
like learn about
other people's lives and their
connections to technology how they got
into technology their world view and
stuff which is definitely one of my
favorite parts of the job which if
you've noticed in my videos i've been
doing that a lot and inviting like other
people my friends colleagues friends of
friends colleagues of college people
that i know so that i can just talk to
more people because it's fun but right
now i'm here to thank the sponsor of
today's vlog which is nordvpn i'm sure
you all know what nordvpn is by now but
for those who don't it's a really easy
to use vpn service that really helps you
to keep your identity and security and
privacy safe online they've got over 5
300 servers in 60 countries which means
that the speed is amazing you can
literally choose to vpn in from anywhere
and in fact it's true it's been
confirmed that nordvpn is the fastest
vpn out there and for you techies who
are concerned about vpns in general they
have diskless servers that store no data
or configurations on site and so your
browsing is completely safe they've also
got an advanced anti-malware feature
called threat protection it's the next
step in protecting the users and
offering a safer and smoother online
experience it's literally so easy to use
nordvpn and so get the exclusive nordvpn
deal here which is also linked in the
description box it's risk free with
nordvpn's 30-day money-back guarantee
thank you again to nordvpn for
sponsoring i've got to go and make some
slides for hong kong academy which is
ending tomorrow which is unreal and i'll
see you in the next vlog y'all bye
[Music]